[Music]
holy
shirt balls
what
is the bad place like to start
saying something I wanted to say for a
very long time surprise idiots you're
all in the bad place
that's right nerds everything around you
all you can see is an elaborate system
of torture designed just for you
sorry
we're in the bad place why are you
revealing this now
holy
shirt balls
what
wow
okay
yo Mikey Sean
come on out
is everything okay ride as rain Mikey my
boy so Chidi and I are gonna go to the
bad place what trust me I've got this
that's our decision let's hit it what
about real level no it's me and Chidi
call the train
point of order I don't accept this offer
the real mistakes were Jason
you said any two of us it's me and
shitty let's do it to it
Michael I just found enough skill
precedent in the rules that might just
save everyone
don't need it
okay
ready when you are boss
Eleanor what's going on it took me a
while to figure it out
but just now as we were all fighting and
yelling at each other and each one of us
demanding we should go to the bad place
taught to myself man this is torture and
then it hit me
they're never gonna call a train to take
us to the bad place
they can't
because we're already here
this is the bad place
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man
I can't believe you figured it out
yo God you ruined everything you know
that
babe there you are I've been let me stop
you can I guess you've been worried sick
about me
I'm headed to the gym
sure why not I'm quite confused let me
explain gorgeous I don't know what this
place is but it is certainly not the
good place Michael is forking with us
Michael what do we do here I don't know
apparently the bad place knows that one
of you actually belongs down there with
them and they want that person to get
inside the obeliska they're going to
take all of you I can't go I'm too young
to die and too old to eat off the kids
and then you what a stupid age I am I've
never survived down there they should
check out of there she's a pear-shaped
she'd fit right in oh excuse me you wish
you could have a bite of this pair I'll
go I deserve to go you guys can stay
holy shirt you guys don't you
get it Michael is torturing us that's
why our lives have been so miserable
since the moment we got here this isn't
the good place it's the bad place
[Music]
it's a Torture Museum famous examples of
bad behavior and explanations of the
torture they earned is there a gift
y'all Jason this is hell of course it's
a gift shop it's the least horrifying
room it's the Hall of low grade
crappiness
first person to floss in an open plan
office
well she deserves to be tortured she's a
monster this was the safest place I
could think of no one ever comes in here
guys if you do leave this room you're
going to see things that will haunt you
for eternity
okay back soon bye hey hey
be careful okay
be careful
yeah
oh Eleanor are you worried about me
yeah I'm worried I mean because you're
our ticket out of here genius don't go
getting all goopy on me I'm not worried
about them I'll be fine
first men send an unsolicited picture of
his genitals
first waiter to approach a diner with an
empty plate and sarcastically say
I guess you hated it first white person
to grow dreadlocks and first person to
call Ultimate Frisbee ultimate these two
rules my love
sweet Dew Drop I have written you a
three hour spoken word Jazz Opera
Eleanor less and more who's it for for
you my Dew Drop cream of the crap top to
the bop to the pop
too no version of Heaven for anyone
would ever include three hours of this
we're in the bad place aren't we
damn it that was a real trip for
biscuits and now we're all wet Daddy-o I
never even got to play my stupid
triangle attempt 57 attempt 99 attempt
108. I've analyzed some recent data
Eleanor always seems to realize that
they're in the bad place just at the
moment excuse me
sorry the door was open so I just came
in did you just say I'm in the bad place
attempt 109. I've closed and locked the
door yep and we're ready to go
hang on wait a minute you know what holy
smokes this is the bad place this is the
bad place this is the bad place this is
the bad place the bed's getting angry
this is the bad place
oh oh this is the bad place
I mean why even bother at this point I'm
obviously never gonna get it right I'm
Eleanor I'm so smart I'm actually in the
bad place
Sean still thinks I'm on version two I
just keep lying to him it's really bad
but I
I mean I have to keep trying I'm in too
deep and I'm really fat right now I'm
stress eating and I'm gaining weight in
my thighs I mean look at that
[Music]
it doesn't matter this one doesn't even
count I simply cannot expect Chidi to
decide
is there something messed up with this
place we keep fighting with each other
none of the TVs get the NFL Red Zone
Channel
my soulmate doesn't even know who Blake
Bortles is I know this sounds crazy but
think we're in the bad place
Jason figured it out Jason the zarolo
point yeah this one hurts
oh
foreign